I'm really excited that the project that Udacity and Figure Eight are
doing together is focused on disaster response.
The Figure Eight creates software that people use to train their machine learning models.
So, I used Figure Eight to respond to a lot of disasters before I joined the company.
For a lot of these disasters,
we have data that we can go back and look at.
We can use our data science knowledge to build
machine learning models that can automate some of processing the next time around.
While this Nanodegree could have taken any kind of dataset,
they're taking one where immediately is going to have a positive impact on the world.
So, it fills my heart to know that a lot of
really smart people are going to be analyzing this in new ways,
and that's going to help us have
a positive impact in the world as we respond to future disasters.